since I last addressed Canadians there
have been ongoing discussions with
foreign ministers senior intelligence
and military officials including the
fourth meeting of our Incident Response
Group there have been important
developments regarding the potential
causes of this deadly crash developments
of which Canadians should be made aware
the news will undoubtedly come as a
further shock to the families who are
already grieving in the face of this
unspeakable tragedy we have intelligence
from multiple sources including our
allies and our own intelligence the
evidence indicates that the plane was
shot down by an Iranian surface-to-air
missile this may well have been
unintentional this new information
reinforces the need for a thorough
investigation into this matter
Canada is working with its allies to
ensure that a thorough and credible
investigation is conducted to determine
the causes of this fatal crash
foreign minister faso egypt shopping
spoke with Iranian Foreign Minister
Zarif Minister Shum pang made it clear
the Canadian officials must immediately
be granted access to Iran in order to
provide consular services identify the
victims
and participate in a thorough
investigation he also condemned Iranian
strikes the targeted military bases in
Iraq where coalition forces including
Canadians are currently stationed
ministers Minister Zarif committed to
continuing this dialogue with Canada as
we seek answers
you